hello freak [ __ ] click boom order i
ordered the silver black bam bam bam and
then at the end I had to get the [ __ ]
cold for I iTunes a sample I woke my
wife up in the middle of the [ __ ] out of
it she really did time to get the [ __ ]
out in so are you [ __ ] crazy waking
me up at 12:15 these stupid [ __ ]
phone there's gonna be lines around the
block at those Apple stores it's it's
crazy it's like those sneaker lines when
you see those people they're out to buy
sneakers for the supreme lines now
Supremes got a whole thing I mean kid
they wait in line for three or four days
now and over what almost weekly but I'll
show you the [ __ ] you're probably gonna
freak out when I show you what they're
waiting please do it shovels bricks with
just the word supreme written on it
shovels and bricks t-shirts are the main
thing what is supreme exactly it's a
brand it's a streetwear brand and people
wait in line for bricks I'll show you
that's [ __ ] kids today this is what
happens when kids don't go outside they
don't play
they don't play sports and they stay at
home they just play video games Nancy
Reagan's fault with it just say no these
kids smoke dope they see life for what
it is yo I'm gonna wait in line for an
hour for [ __ ] break look at that
supreme crowbar they sell a crowbar so
the crowbar we just have like the name
supreme on it
okay who's using that no one uses it
it's like that it's real you have to
look into the brand a little bit to
understand it but it's sort of part of
the joke almost there making parody of
the craziness of it all by just throwing
their brand name on stuff and people are
buying into it go back to the page so
supremely we ran top ten non wearable
supreme products Jesus Christ they have
fire extinguishers yeah new chucks but
some of the clothes are cool if
nunchucks
it's just depend you gotta be really
into it and some people are really into
it like I said they wait in line for
days a lot of them though are making
money off of it because they can buy it
for 40 or 50 bucks and flip it for 200 I
don't understand like why is everybody
buying this limited limited quantities
is what
but what is the big deal about supreme I
cut you have to look into the history up
there's some YouTube videos you can look
up
you sound like Getty Bravo gotta look
into it it's really hard to explain and
I like can't even it'd take me a half an
hour to get into it I don't want to
hijack the show supreme right now so
well I just never I wasn't aware of this
I thought it was just like a t-shirt
that's where it started you so Josh
Martin wears him he spends a lot of
money he's a fool
well he wears those goddamn Yeezys that
you were too I don't spend much money
imma get in for retail I wouldn't buy
them otherwise yeah Josh Martin is like
into every trendy thing everything that
comes out he's like way ahead of the
crowd supreme exactly Jesus Christ Joey
I don't give a [ __ ] I didn't know about
this thing you buy a hammer
it's a supreme on it the fact they sell
nunchucks is hilarious supreme nunchucks
did we wait on line we would navigate
not for anything like last night was
watching something the real story about
the Godfather and they showed when they
released the Godfather at New York and
that were lines yeah the movies yeah I'm
sure waited in line to go see Star Wars
but not three [ __ ] days before not
for a hammer what did they camp out for
back then they kept out for something
really I don't feel like the first I
ever saw it was iPhones when the first
iPhones were out I remember going to the
mall and going what in the [ __ ] am I
seeing and there was a giant lion
outside the Apple Store and this was
like when one of the first iPhones was
coming out and I was like why are you
waiting for a phone you don't have a
phone already like is this the only way
to get the phone I was it was all so
confusing but it was a thing where
people would wait in line and then they
would look at each other and I remember
when I remember when they were waiting
in line for Harry Potter when Harry
Potter was coming out and people would
drive him by and they were yell and now
Dumbledore dies at the end another
they're yelling out all these different
spoilers all I typed in was waiting in
line for in Google and the only things
that come up are iPhone supreme and
iPhone 8 or gasps yeah that's right the
seventies with the flag yeah
red green a yellow flag what was that
there was like in the mid 70s there was
a gas shortage
so green meant that you got gas if you
had an odd-numbered like if your license
plate under the nod yellow was even and
then red was were shut down [ __ ] oh
yeah that's you remember that they had
to fly in 73 to 75 maybe something like
I don't know the exact dates
[Applause]
[Music]